so we're told this is the graph of
function f right over here and then they
tell us that function g is defined as
g of x is equal to one third f of x what
is the graph of g and if we were doing
this on khan academy this is a
screenshot from our mobile app it has
multiple choices but i thought we would
just try to sketch it so pause pause
this video maybe in your mind imagine
what you think the graph of g is going
to look like or at least how you would
tackle it
all right so g of x is equal to one
third f of x so for example we can see
here that f of three is equal to
negative three
so g of three should be one-third that
so it should be negative 1
likewise so g of 3 would be right over
there and likewise g of negative 3 what
would that be
well f of negative 3 is 3 so g of
negative 3 is going to be 1 3 that or
it's going to be equal to 1.
f of 0 is 0 1 3 of that is still 0 so g
of 0 is still going to be right over
there and we know that's going to happen
there and there as well and so we
already have a sense of what this graph
is going to look like the function g is
going to look something
like
something like this i'm just connecting
the dots and they did give us some dots
that we can use as reference points so
the graph of g is going to look
something like this it gets a little bit
flattened out or a little bit squished
or smushed a little bit to look
something like that and you would pick
the choice that looks like that let's do
another example
so here we are told this is the graph of
f of x and it's defined by this
expression
what is the graph of g of x and g of x
is this so pause this video and think
about it again
all right now the key realization is is
it looks like g of x is if you were to
take all the terms of f of x and
multiply it by 2 or at least if you were
to multiply the absolute value by 2 and
then if you were to multiply this
negative 2 by 2. so it looks like g of x
is equal to 2
times
2 times f of x
and we could even set up a little table
here this is another way that we can
think about it we can think about x
we can think about f of x
and now we could think about g of x
which should be two times that
so we can see that when x is equal to
zero
f of x is equal to one so g of x should
be equal to two because it's two times f
of x
so g of x is going to be equal to or g
of 0 i should say is going to be equal
to 2.
what about when at x equals we'll say
when x equals 3
when x equals 3 f of x is negative 2
g of x is going to be 2 times that
because it's 2 times f of x so it's
going to be negative 4. so g of x or i
should say g of 3 is going to be
negative 4 it's going to be right over
there
and then maybe let's think about one
more point so
f of five
is equal to zero
g of five is going to be two times that
which is still going to be equal to zero
so it's going to be right over there and
so the graph is going to look something
like this i'm just really just
connecting
i'm just connecting the dots trying to
draw some straight lines
it's going to look something like this
you can see it's kind of stretched in
the vertical direction so if you were
doing this on khan academy it'd be
multiple choice you look for the graph
that looks like that
let's do a few more examples
so here we're given a function g
is a vertically scaled version of f so
we can see that g is a vertically scaled
version of f
the functions are graphed where f is a
solid and g is dash yeah we see that
what is the equation of g in terms of f
so pause this video and try to think
about it
well the way that i would tackle this is
once again let's do it with a table
let's see the relationship between f and
g
so
this column is x
this column is f of x
and then this column is g of x i'll make
another column right over here and so
let's see some interesting points so
when actually i could pick 0 but 0 is
maybe less interesting than this point
over here so this is when x is equal to
negative three
f of negative three is negative three
what is g of negative three it looks
like it is negative nine
when f is
when x is zero f of zero is negative 2.
what is g of 0 it is equal to negative
6.
and so we already see a pattern forming
whatever f is g is 3 times that whatever
f is g is 3 times that
and so we don't even actually need these
big columns but we can see that g of x
is equal to 3 times
f of x so that is the equation of g in
terms of f